Morty can you hit the ignore button on
that I'm not hitting the Ignore button Rick we're going
to help those people in distress if we
doing that happens right we just ignore
the call huh you know and maybe we
should take off looks like anything's
going on Oh Morty no we have to help people
crap I think it's dead God more you died
of toxicity due to all the drugs and
alcohol swirling about in my system well
Rick you know they say don't do drugs
but I think this might be a case for and
alcohol Morty yeah and alcohol somebody
get a memo to all the characters in
those Alien movies stat yeah no kidding
you know I never thought I'd say this
but thank God you drink all those drugs
and alcohol you know you don't drink
drugs whatever I don't know I'm innocent
we got some new Rick and Morty in a
bunch of you guys were asking me about
what's up with this episode 2 rumor so I
wanted to do a video explaining what's
going on and some of my favorite Rick on
drugs moments this year is probably the
best way to promote the series and the
movie at the same time so if you guys
are wondering what's going on here
they were actually hired by the alien
covenant movie the people at Fox to make an ad for their alien covenant movie
so they get to promo Rick and Morty
season 3 at the same time but even if
you don't care about alien covenant I'm
still going to do a giveaway it's just a
movie gift card for two imax passes you
can use it for whatever movie you want
to go to you don't have to go see alien
covenant separately McDonald's has
already started reacting to the Szechuan
sauce in an official capacity now they
can't say like yes we're bringing this
back on X day but because the
live-action Mulan movie is being made by
Disney do not be surprised if that's
when you see it come back so I don't
they were going to wait 9 seasons on
Rick and Morty to get there but the
logic is sound Rick's saying there's too
much crap in his body for the facehugger
to handle and just falls right off his
face the whole twist is the first
episode Morty having to shove that seat
up his butt is because Rick has done it
too many times we're gonna have to go
through interdimensional customs so
you're gonna have to do me a real solid
Oh when we get to customs
I'm gonna need you to take these seeds
into the bathroom and I'm gonna need you to put them way up inside your butthole
Morty I put them way up inside there as
far as they can throw a cheese Rick I
really don't want to have to do that
somebody kind of do it Morty these seeds
aren't gonna get through customs unless
they're in someone's rectum Morty no
fall right out of mine I've done this
too many times for tea you're young he's
got your whole life ahead of you
and your anal cavity is still taut yet
malleable you gotta do it for grandpa
Morty you gotta put these seeds in such
a putt good come on Morty please more
you have to do it more
auto-erotic assemble a ssin is an
episode where he spends almost the
entire time drinking on drugs with unity
in wouldn't you be doing that too if you
were hanging out with Christina
Hendricks there's like a good list of
WTFs on Rick and Morty but the stadium
scene is one of my favorite funny dark
moments because it's just so nasty I
want as many people as you can find that
look like my father to come watch me and
cheer
while I do this oh snap powdered
neutronium in feta Tron you know what I
can make with this stuff oh look I I
shouldn't come on it's not every day
that I'm in town it's for old times sake
uh okay what the hell we can purify the
resin and make fractal dust oh I was
thinking velocity knees but uh oh man
Rick can't party with the whole planet I
can do whatever you do in roar baby wait
stop hold it not like this we need a
hang glider and a crotchless Uncle Sam
cost you and I want the entire field of
your largest stadium covered end to end
with naked redheads and I want the
stands packed with every man that
remotely resembles my father the
training montage at the end of something
rigid this way comes that's my favorite
version of summer just totally hardcore
Rick you like that how do you like that
oh why because sometimes what you really need is for someone else to pay a
horrible price they still haven't said
when season three is going to drop a lot
of you been asking me on Twitter about
the IMDB thing where it says new
episodes returning tomorrow the problem
with IMDB is that it can be edited by
anyone so you can't really trust it
until you see it so I'll believe new
Rick and Morty is coming when I actually
see it in front of my face but I say
that it'll probably drop tomorrow
something hilarious will happen so do
monitor the Adult Swim livestream every
once in awhile but I think when it comes
back
they won't troll April Fool's Day style
and just drop it out of nowhere they'll
actually say it's coming on X Day and
they'll start rolling out weekly
episodes we're not quite at the summer
yet but I'm not expecting episodes for
at least a couple more weeks and
probably not till later in June but
they'll tell us stuff when they can tell
us stuff did that total dicks about it
and they'll be more promos like this -
we haven't seen a genuine promo for this
yet we only saw that quick pickle Rick
promo at the end of the first episode
and I know everybody has the theory that
that is not the first episode but
technically it is if you look at the
schedule episode 1 the rick shank
redemption that was the episode that
aired episode 2 is rick man seing the
stone so they'll continue to replay
episode 1 till episode 2 drops but the
actual premiere will probably just be
episode 2 well let me know in the
comments what's your favorite rick and
morty most messed up rick on drugs
moment he's done a lot the kalaxian
crystals is another great moment i got
the crystal all right you did it Morty
rick wait there's something you need to
know i couldn't have done it without
linkler he said that he was really
sorry and that he loves you like a
father he only wanted you to accept him
and he hopes that his final act would
redeem him in your eyes he sacrificed
himself to save all of us rick he died
well at least he didn't die in vain he
got these crystals and these babies
should save this lame-ass party hold up
a dub dub play something something plays
it's actually a twist on dune in the
spice melange so even when they're doing
really crazy drugged up moments they are
riffing on big sci-fi series which i
think is one of the best parts of the
series but hour-long watch continues I
feel like Rick and Morty fans and Game
of Thrones fans have had the longest
wait for new episodes in the last series
so leave all your requests for
Rick and Morty bonus videos in the comments below while you wait for that click here for
all my season 3 videos and you can click
here for a brand new Wonder Woman and
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight!